this great big story is made possible by
Lexus experience amazing light is very
powerful for me yet it's also something
that I'm desperate to hold on to it's
going you know the lights are going out
so I'm struggling to hold on to the
light
that was an art school in 79 and the eye
doctor said mr. arrow you have an eye
disease you will be blind in 20 years
and I said oh you're telling me this bad
news I'm gonna make the best art I can
ever make goddamnit you know I'm gonna
do it
I see very bright lights and I can't see
dim light at all I've never seen a star
in my whole life for example I was
looking at that view towards Manhattan
what I see is a very small area maybe
about half the size of my thumb and all
around that it's not black it's not
white it's not gray it just doesn't
exist that's how I see everything else
is just non-existence there are a number
of visually impaired visual artists now
and we do have a facet in the art world
[Music]
my painting is a process where you use
your mind as much as your eyes it's a
very long time exposure made in a
darkened room with a flashlight
the person will be there and I will turn
off the lights and wherever I don't
paint with the flashlight it'll be black
in the picture
the fear I have about blindness is very
strong it's a feeling that my life will
not be worthwhile if I can't say but as
a totally blind person I will still be
able to do the light painting so it is a
comfort to know that my work is strong
even though maybe in the future we'll be
able to see it
[Music]
darkness is the cannabis and the light
is my brush with light painting you can
create new worlds into darkness my name
is Hana booth Tomo and I paint would
like I live in Finland we have amazing
nature here we have a long summer nights
that are warm and full of light but on
the opposite there is also this dark
part
it's called polar night it starts in
December and it lasts for about 50 days
the Sun doesn't rise above the horizon
at all and for a light painter that is
quite good I do long exposure
photography which is a photographic
technique that allows me to draw with
light the exposure times can vary from
seconds to hours and the idea is to use
the light sources as approaches or
pencils and the dark surroundings are
the cannabis when I start I might do
some sketches on paper after that I go
to the location I search for details
that I want to emphasize with some light
treatment it will start to look like a
completely a new place going to dark
woods or to abandoned house you first
think that oh I don't want to go there
because there's just so nasty looking
dark places but too light painting I
have examined these places and they look
beautiful you see that place differently
[Music]
after I got hurt it was painful to sit
on the sidelines and watch other people
play sports and participate and not be
involved when I started this interest in
photography it was an opportunity to get
back into sports again my name is Lauren
Washington and I'm a photographer
when I was 21 years old I wanted to be a
baseball player
I was playing one evening and I hit a
great double that was a lousy triple and
I slid into third base came in contact
with the other players knee and it
pinched my spinal cord the result of
that was paralysis I'm a c-56
quadriplegic I've been in the wheelchair
for the past 30 years
it wasn't until almost 20 years after my
injury that I picked up a camera
adapting the camera is kind of an
extension of learning how to deal with a
disability I cannot use my right fingers
what I figured out is that I could use
an external shutter control with my
mouth and take the photograph the type
of photography that I do is about people
who are involved in adaptive sports and
I felt my best photographs were of
people with disabilities because they
saw in me somebody that they could open
up to when I take photos of athletes I
want to show them as somebody who works
hard who competes hard and who wants to
win that really chose more about the
athlete than the disability when I first
started shooting adaptive sports I
immediately set my goal to taking
photographs at the Paralympics I got the
phone call from the United States
Olympic Committee that they were
interested in me going to Rio de Janeiro
in 2016 there was some of the most
amazing athletes there and it worked out
same is what I've always had to deal
with is you just got to try it probably
the first day it's not gonna work so
well but after that you just start
getting better and better at everything
you do the hog well they're huge
I know it's like seeing our bus in the
water and she looks at you with those
big eyes and she stares at ya just
beautiful
that's when you know that she's laying
you mean that's an WOD ppattani
he's a photographer and in 2015 he won
the grand prize in national Geographics
traveler photo contest for his photo
whale whisperer so we're talking about
what it feels like to come face-to-face
with one of the largest mammals on our
planet the first time he was here oka
partita we knew we're gonna see the
whales because we're hearing them and
when they're nearby your whole body
resonates it's so strong well I love the
sound of the wealth and she's as
beautiful as seeing them he's underwater
and off in the distance I saw the silat
of the whale big being sulla that looked
like a submarine with a feature like a
big object and as he got closer things
became clearer donors the island is 15
that's a big whale it's a very being
will
the most profound feeling he had was a
connection to the whale herself she
looks at you right into your eyes yeah
and you feel the connection or there's a
mama connection you feel accepted on
words been diving for 17 years and his
photographs are more than just pictures
go to the photo maker and I tried to
share them because people that are send
Ivan doesn't know the ocean they might
start to pay attention to the ocean and
I like whales let's remind them that we
share the world with very very wise and
therefore animals down there